Hello again, dear viewers.
You’ve caught me during my break.
What?
Even researchers at the SCP Foundation need
a little downtime now and then.
And considering they revoked my playtime privileges
with The Living Lego and the Nerfing Gun after
the unfortunate incident in the Site-19 Break
Room, I’ve been downgraded to keeping myself
occupied with this little rubber ball.
“I have a ball.
Perhaps you'd like to bounce it,” they said.
Seems innocent enough, doesn’t it?
Oh, have you learned nothing?
Almost any object, even something as innocuous
as a Teddy Bear or a plastic paddling pool,
can hide secrets.
Sure, any avid basketball fan will happily
tell you that ball is life.
But sometimes, when you’re dealing with
anomalies, a ball can also… be death.
Such is the case of SCP-018, also known as
The Super Ball.
An anomaly so powerful that the Foundation
has even used it to help recontain SCP-682
during a breach.
To the untrained observer, it really isn’t
much to look at.
A small, red rubber ball, about six centimeters
in diameter, produced by the Wham-O company
in 1969.
Yeah, we were as surprised as you to find
out that good ol’ Dr. Wondertainment had
nothing to do with this little number.
You might also be surprised by just how extensive
the containment procedures are for SCP-018
- After all, it’s rare that a competently
non-sentient anomaly makes its way into the
Euclid class.
This little rubber ball is kept in a specially-made
titanium-alloy metal restraint, submerged
in a dense polyethylene holding tank, filled
with a special endothermic compound that draws
the kinetic energy out of its surroundings.
Anyone entering the chamber needs to wear
a unique kind of reinforced plate armor, and
if SCP-018 ever manages to escape its containment
tank, nearby personnel are advised to treat
it as they would an active shooter situation.
Lock yourself in a nearby room, duck down
below any cover you can find, and wait for
armed containment units to show up and take
control of the situation.
At this point, you probably have a lot of
questions, chief among them being: Why is
this children’s toy being given more security
precautions than most serial killers?
The ball was first discovered when a cleaning
and disposal company was hired to empty out
an old Wham-O warehouse of some defunct merchandise.
One of the movers, Roy Fischler, embraced
his inner child when he saw a red, rubber
ball sitting among all the dusty boxes of
expired silly putty and broken remote control
robots.
He thought to himself, “what’s the harm
in having a little fun here?
It’s all going into the trash anyway.”
This would prove to be a terrible mistake
for all involved.
The anomalous property of SCP-018 is the fact
that it’s able to bounce at 200% efficiency
every time it’s bounced, increasing at an
exponential rate with each bounce unless it’s
stopped by some equivalent force.
So when Roy decided to toss that little red
ball onto the ground, he’d unleashed a destructive
force into that warehouse that was more powerful
than he ever could have imagined.
With every bounce, the ball increased its
height and speed, ricocheting across the floor,
walls, and ceiling like a bullet run amok.
And it was only just getting started.
The workers hit the deck as the item that
would later be dubbed SCP-018 decided to put
the “ball” in “ballistic.”
It smashed light fixtures.
Knocked over piles of boxes.
Smashed through forklifts.
When one worker tried to catch it, it left
a red-hot, ball-shaped hole in the middle
of his palm.
It wasn’t long before the ball had built
up such speed that the warehouse could no
longer contain it.
It blasted out of the wall and rocketed into
the nearby city, ready to cause more abject
chaos wherever it went.
Windows were shattered.
Street lights were annihilated.
Cars crashed.
Thankfully, no humans were killed by the rampaging
rubber menace, but in total five people were
injured - And one unfortunate pigeon was utterly
obliterated on impact.
It went on for several days, with the ball
reaching over 100 kilometers per hour at several
points, before finally coming to rest at a
nearby lake.
At which point, it was retrieved by Foundation
personnel.
There were two silver linings to this incredibly
strange anomalous incident: The first was,
as previously alluded to, nobody actually
died.
The second was that, due to the incredible
speeds at which SCP-018 moved, none of the
civilian witnesses had any idea what they’d
just encountered.
As far as anomalous discoveries go, this was
pretty much as close to a win as you can get.
But for one ambitious researcher, it was far
more than just a pleasingly non-violent initial
containment story - It was a doorway to improving
the Foundation’s technology as a whole.
Meet Dr. Brian Karella.
He’s what you might call a maverick, a blue
sky thinker, always on his grind.
The cornerstone of Dr. Karella’s philosophy
was that the Foundation should be making more
active use of its benign anomalies to help
track down and contain their more ornery foes.
While everyone else around him seemed to only
see a little rubber nuisance that was better
locked away, Dr. Karella saw the immense potential
in SCP-018.
Namely, in providing a vital enhancement to
another piece of Foundation technology: The
SCP-A5 Armor.
It goes without saying that working for the
SCP Foundation is an incredibly dangerous
job, especially if you’re part of one of
the Foundation’s myriad mobile task forces.
The hunt for anomalies can lead to all kinds
of strange and inhospitable terrains.
Before it was contained, SCP-096 was famously
captured on an icy, frozen tundra on top of
a bleak mountain.
Because of incidents like this, the Foundation
had first invested money in the SCP-A5 Tactical
Armor Suit.
Think of them like the Foundation’s answer
to the Iron Man suit.
However, when dressed in several hundred pounds
of reinforced metal, something important suffers
along the way: Mobility.
It isn’t exactly easy to lug all that equipment
around.
And when an anomaly is heading for the hills
at high speeds, being well-defended doesn’t
count for much if you’re already ten miles
behind the target in pursuit.
This, in Dr. Karella’s mind, was exactly
where SCP-018 came into play.
If that little red ball was built into the
foot of an SCP-A5 Armor suit, it could be
used to bounce the operative wearing it to
tremendous heights.
This would allow them to not only give chance
against fast-moving anomalies but also cover
difficult terrain and even scale great heights
in a mere instant.
But it wasn’t just an increase to mobility
that SCP-018 integration offered to the SCP-A5
suit.
Picture this: With SCP-108 fused to the sole
of the suit’s reinforced metal foot, lending
it 200% bouncing efficiency, it could unleash
a deadly, concrete-shattering kick.
The kind of thing that would leave you singing
in falsetto for the rest of your life if you
were lucky enough to survive it, if you know
what I mean.
To Dr. Karella, it was a match made in heaven.
It could increase both the mobility and combat
effectiveness of the suits by a considerable
margin.
And seeing as SCP-018 literally didn’t have
a mind of its own, there’s no way it could
suddenly go rogue during a mission and compromise
everything - just as Able had during his stint
as a Mobile Task Force operator before they
ran out of targets for him and he started
slaughtering his own comrades.
Dr. Karella was so confident in the efficacy
of this idea, he contacted the O5 Council
personally to request approval for this little
pet project.
This approval was granted, on a purely experimental
basis.
The technology would have to prove itself
before being put into common use.
It wasn’t exactly what Karella wanted to
hear, but it was a step in the right direction.
He just needed the perfect opportunity to
put them to the test.
And then it came: SCP-682, the Infamous Hard
to Destroy Reptile, breached containment.
It’d somehow adapted a cloaking ability
and escaped further from the site it was being
held at than ever before.
The next time it was spotted was over two
weeks later, causing pandemonium in the Amazon
Rainforest, devouring tribesmen and wreaking
havoc on the local ecosystem.
They needed to get on the scene fast and put
that monster down before the damage it caused
was irreparable, and news of the Beast in
the Amazon leaked out into the local area.
And thankfully, Dr. Karella had just the tool
for the job.
Field Agent Hammersmith was fitted with an
SCP-A5 suit, complete with the SCP-018 enhancement
in his dominant right leg.
He was dispatched, and immediately, the augmented
suit began to show its efficacy.
Agent Hammersmith bounded above the treeline
at incredible speeds, using the HUD in the
suit’s mask to track the heat signature
of SCP-682 moving among the trees below him.
He’d been able to bind a tracking collar
to the beast’s neck during an earlier engagement,
but now the true battle was on.
His heart was pounding, adrenaline coursing
through his veins, but he’d been ensured
that even 682 would have a hard time tearing
through his suit’s armor.
A commander directing him through an earpiece
told him now was the time to engage, before
682 detected his presence and began developing
countermeasures.
Dr. Karella was watching a live feed from
the control room, confident that his 018-augmented
suit would do the job.
Following his orders to the letter, Hammersmith
descended down onto 682 from above.
However, before he could make contact, the
reptile swiped him with its tail, sending
his body sailing into a nearby tree.
However, the suit stood firm.
He felt the impact, but the actual damage
was minimal.
Now, it was time for him to face off against
the beast, one on one.
He didn’t have time to be afraid.
As the beast descended upon him, fangs bared,
he gave it a swift kick to the bottom jaw,
tearing off half of its face.
But anyone who knows SCP-682 would tell you
that simply removing its bottom jaw wouldn’t
even slow 682 down.
It was relentless, attacking Hammersmith with
its fangs and jaws.
It tore deep ruts into the suit’s metal,
but the suit was still managing to keep its
occupant safe.
Then Hammersmith struck back.
Kick after kick, augmented by the 200% power
of the Super Ball, sliced huge chunks from
the reptile’s body.
He kicked in its chest, kicked off limbs,
and with a final mighty kick, even managed
to bisect the beast in the middle.
Of course, even that wouldn’t keep it down
for long, but with the hum of evacuation and
containment helicopters rapidly approaching,
Hammersmith breathed a sigh of relief.
Back in the control room, everyone celebrated
- Dr. Karella most of all, vindicated in his
belief that SCP-018 could save the day.
And then Agent Hammersmith, without even thinking,
rested his right foot on the floor just that
little bit too firmly.
The sudden bounce sent Hammersmith a mile
into the air.
His Foundation-trained composure evaporated;
all he could do was scream as he blasted up
into the clouds, then began to plummet.
Back in the control room, everyone could see
a live feed of Agent Hammersmith hurtling
into a nearby lake and landing with an epic
splash.
While the regenerating remains of SCP-682
were contained and brought back to the nearest
containment site, another team was sent in
to retrieve the heavily injured Agent Hammersmith.
His medical examination afterward revealed
he’d suffered two broken legs, seven broken
ribs, a missing arm, and a skull fracture.
If he hadn’t been wearing the suit, his
mangled remains probably would have been devoured
by the local piranhas by now.
But despite that minor hiccup in the plan,
Dr. Karella was still delighted with the results,
and immensely proud of the little red ball
that could.
In his closing remarks on the incident, he
appended a final note to the SCP-018 file,
reading:
“Don't worry, it's fixed.
But, I have some more ideas.
If I can be granted the use of some water
from SCP-006, as well as some other SCPs,
I can deliver you a set of SCP-A5 armor and
an agent that can capture any, if not all,
rogue or unattained SCPs.
All I'm waiting on is your approval.”
Now go check out “Why Everyone Wants to
Eat this Corpse - SCP-1176” and “SCP-1025
- Encyclopedia of Common Diseases” for more
anomalous objects that are full of surprises!